[Music]
hello welcome to our session this is
choosing the right Google compute engine
instance type for your workload my name
is Hanna Youssef I'm a product manager
on Google compute map on Google compute
engine and and today during this session
I'll be walking you through the
different virtual machine types
available on our platform as well as the
new infrastructure announcements that
we're making today during the next 2019
I'll focus on describing the different
options available to you the
capabilities of the new instance types
in the new VMs and also we'll walk
through some guidelines to help you make
decisions about the right VM
infrastructure for your workload I hope
that by the end of the session you will
have a clearer picture of the different
VM types available and I hope you will
find it easier to pick the right
infrastructure for any work load that
you bring to Google Cloud before we
start we want to let you know that we do
have a Dory for the session so please
feel free to go to their next
application and add any questions you
have for us we'll have some time to
answer any questions you have in the
Dory at the end of the session so let's
start by talking about the applications
that you are running today on the cloud
I'm sure if I ask this room will come up
with a list of 100 or possibly more
different application types different
workloads and different architectures
that you're looking to run on GCP or on
your cloud provider some of you might be
focused on running high performance web
applications others might be looking for
ways to run your ERP systems efficiently
in the cloud or maybe you're simply
looking for the ability to burst to the
cloud and finish a job that you have at
the moment that you're thinking about a
bad job so how easy did you find the
process of matching your needs to the
capabilities provided by your cloud
provider do you find it easy to find the
right VM type at the right cost with the
right performance in the right locations
that you're looking at do you find that
sometimes confusing to look through a
very big and large catalog of instance
types with different features and
capability
and find it difficult to compare them I
bet you do
I personally sometimes find it very
confusing to look through all of these
options available I think one thing that
also makes this a more complex question
for us to answer is the fact that your
workloads are typically not stable what
you start with might need to change your
performance requirements might change
your budget might change and we need to
figure out how easy it is for you to
make these changes as you get them we
believe that this should be simple this
is why in GCP from day one we really
focus on taking a very different
approach to our instance types we
understand that you need simplicity so
that your decision making is easy and
effective without requiring you to have
a PhD in our catalog or study that for
hours we know that you need flexibility
because your needs change because your
requirements come up every day new
requirements come up every day as your
profile workload or as your business
grows and you need different
requirements or different resources for
example we've also pirate eyes
efficiency as one thing we always look
at when trying to introduce new
capabilities into other infrastructure
and efficiency is very important over
here because on the cloud you shouldn't
need to over buy you shouldn't need to
over provision you should find something
that fits exactly what you're looking
for and what you're gonna benefit from
so let's look at this process in more
details how do you actually pick the
right VM shape on Google cloud how do
you match your exact needs to that
available from our platform we believe
that for 90 percent of your workloads
this should be a very simple process
where you need to do no comparisons and
you need to find what you're looking for
with exactly one click and this is why
we've really focused on having that as
one of our core pillars as we created
our general purpose VM we wanted to make
them simply truly general-purpose they
are designed to be simple flexible and
fit the majority of your workload and we
do that in many ways
first of all we focus with our
general-purpose VMs on giving you
flexible sizing you can simply choose
the number of cores and the amount of
memory that you need at any point of
time and with the ratio that you're
looking for you don't have to choose
from only predefined shapes which might
map to some workloads we have in mind
that might not necessarily be exactly
what you're looking for with the
general-purpose machine types you can
choose more memory more cores or you can
choose a balance and what's very
important in this process is that you
don't need to think or worry about
pricing changing in strange ways as you
change those ratios so by having a very
simple and linear pricing for both cores
and memory that becomes one less
decision you need to think about and one
less factor you need to consider it's
one simple pricing that you can have
across the board what's also very
important about the January purpose
machine types is that with custom
machine types with the custom machine
types available on Google cloud platform
right sizing becomes something that you
can actually do on the cloud so that you
don't over provision and you get exactly
what you're looking for let's talk about
custom machine types
as you can see here these sliders are
actually part of what I like most about
Google compute engine simple sliders
that allow you to just configure the
Machine type to what you have in mind
and what exactly if that's what you're
looking at with custom machine types you
can build an exact fit and you can
prevent any wasted resources and we've
seen our customers use this feature to
actually benefit from more than 19
percent savings versus just using
predefined instances that are available
including predefined instances available
on Google compute engine itself another
great way that custom machine types help
you is that it provides you with
something that we call extended memory
and extended memory is really meant to
break any barriers you have to creating
the exact shape you're looking at so for
example let's take an example of a
workload that has very expensive per
core requirements on any clouds you
typically have to choose the memory that
you're looking for and you get a
predefined amount of course available
with that and then you will have to pay
the licensing for all your course you
don't have any choice with extended
memory you can actually figure out the
amount of memory that you need and then
decrease the number of course that
you're buying with the VM so that you
don't have to bake to pay for extra
licensing that you don't actually need
another great thing about custom machine
types and about the general-purpose VMs
is that we're also aside from giving you
the ability to create the exact fit
shape that you're looking for we also
try to help you with that decision and
help you with figuring out what the
right number and the right fit is we do
this through the right sizing
recommendations so if you've been on the
Google cloud console recently you might
have seen a screen that looks like this
one and what the screen shows you is our
own recommendation and the platform
intelligence that we make available to
you so that you can figure out if what
you're running today is really the most
efficient way to run your workload on
the top here for exam
I have an 8 v CPU VM that I'm not fully
utilizing and because of that Google
compute engine right away gives me a
recommendation that I can actually
downsize to a different VM and directly
save more than 150 dollars per month in
many ways this is meant to give you the
ability so that with custom machine
types and with the right sizing
recommendation you get the exact fit and
you avoid overspending on infrastructure
resources that you don't need another
thing which is really significant and
great about general-purpose VMs is that
they give you a lot of flexibility to
change the attachments that you add to
those VMs a great example is storage so
on a typical day you might think coming
into the cloud that you need locally
attached storage to be able to get the
performance that you're looking for
maybe a few days later after some
performance testing you see that you
actually don't need all that performance
and you prefer to have something that's
network attached and more durable for
your critical data in a typical case you
would have had to change your entire VM
type choose a different one that has
local storage or not local storage with
Google compute engine we try to make
that a much easier process so that you
can just have a VM running on GCE and go
and change the storage mode or the
storage type that you're using with this
VM as you can see here you can choose
the local SSD you can choose persistent
disk which is network attached and you
can even choose among the different
types of persistent attach these are
available to you the main goal of
thinking about our infrastructure this
way and presenting it this way is that
we simplify the process of decision
making and we simplify the process of
operations for him this applies to a lot
of things across Google compute engine a
couple of examples have to do with how
we manage CPU platforms and GPUs
we simply believe that there are
decisions you shouldn't have to spend
time on and there are things that are
intelligent cloud platform should be
able to do automatically for you one
clear example is managing the hardware
upgrade cycle maybe for some of your
workloads you do care about
understanding the underlying CPU
architecture and optimizing your code
for it you might be using certain
instruction sets for example however
from our experience we've seen that most
of the time you actually don't need to
worry about that and you don't need to
think about it
you just need something the trend and
runs well on the cloud and for these
cases we give you the ability to choose
a minimum CPU platform as you see in the
screen under CPU platform this is intel
skylake or later and what that means is
that by simply choosing this box and
choosing that option you give us the
ability to manage the hub the hardware
upgrade cycle on your behalf so that we
can continue to move you to the more
recent infrastructure more efficient
infrastructure as this becomes the most
appropriate one for for us to use and
for you to use without you having to go
and do any work you don't stop the
instance you don't recreate another one
it simply upgrades on your behalf if
we're talking about flexibility another
thing that we believe helps you with
general-purpose VMs is the ability to
choose different accelerator types you
might have been using K ATS for example
at a certain point of time but now want
to experiment with the new three for
GPUs you don't need to go and rebuild
your entire infrastructure again you can
remove on GPU and add another and you're
set to go without having to go back and
figure out if for example the perfect
shape that you've been recommended also
exists with the GPU instances
so to summarize for the january purpose
VMS we covered how a wide variety of
options and of workloads are available
with those general purpose VMs we talked
about how they enable you to run things
that might be very different and have
different resource requirements by
changing the amount of cores and memory
that you have available across different
workloads from databases to applications
mobile gaming and dev fantasy
environments we also discussed the great
flexibility you get with general-purpose
VMs you don't have to spend a lot of
time trying to research or compare the
instances you get custom machine types
which enable you to create an exact fit
for your workloads and even if finding
the exact fit is not a right task you
get recommendations that enable you to
do that
this makes general-purpose VMs great for
a wide variety of workloads and makes
them really a very simple way to get
started without having to rethink or to
look through a very large catalog of
instance types options and compare them
we've seen our customers make great
benefit of these features and these
capabilities and tell us a lot of times
how custom machine types really enabled
them to change their economy to change
the economy of running their
infrastructure and spend their money and
their focus on their operations on or 3d
matters
now let's talk about bursty workloads
many Google cloud customers look for a
better option to run more cost sensitive
and bursty jobs when they need to this
can be the kind of job where you just
need to run thousands of cores for
example for a very short period of time
on the cloud so that you complete a
certain task you have in mind a good
example here is rendering jobs for
example we see a lot of Studios coming
to GCP so that they run a long running a
big rendering job get the tasks done in
a very short period of time by
leveraging thousands of yen's at one
time typically these workloads only care
about the time it takes for them to
complete they might not essentially care
about this being a real-time process
where they are interacting with their
customer in every step of the way and
I'm sure that you would agree that
economics become a very big part of this
decision when you're looking to run tend
of tens of thousands of VMs for a very
short period of time you really don't
want to be spending too much for that
for these cases preemptable VMs is GCPs
recommended solution preemptable VMs are
made for batch check pointed and high
throughput computing they are simply
short running VMs that can run for up to
24 hours and can be preempted at any
point of time and with those constraints
they become 80% cheaper for you to run
the great thing about these vm types is
that they are actually not a separate VM
type it's just a flag that you can add
to any instance at any point of time you
don't have to go and redo your research
or think about some capabilities you
might be missing if you chose
preemptable VMs for example this makes
them ideal for a variety of workloads
from genomics to computational chemistry
to data processing and simulations the
greatest thing about them is that you
get directly 80% of which is a fixed
discount you
predictable pricing without having to
face any unpredictability into this
process as long as you have jobs that
are full tolerant and can manage
preemption you directly get this benefit
again we've seen many GCP customers make
great use of this capability many of
them run tens of thousands of course and
tens of thousands of VMs while saving
money an equation which is typically not
very easy to solve
now let's move to a different workload
let's talk about gaming as an example
multiplayer games specifically are a
great example of a computer intensive
workload we see typically triple-a
titles looking for the fastest and best
experience they can present to their end
customers for these companies frame
processing time is critical if that
ended up happening slower than expected
than their players the gamers would
actually notice that their game is not
performing as expected and it would
impact their experience this is why
we've been working for a very long time
on introducing the new compute optimized
VMs which is one of the new instance
types that we've announced today during
next 2019 compute optimized VMs simply
provide the highest per core performance
on GCP they are the best fit for compute
intensive workloads that might include
triple-a gaming high-performance
computing
and a lot of very high performance
websites and applications these
instances provide more than 40% higher
performance for workloads that are
compute bound and care about single
threaded perf what's great about those
VMs is that with this new introduction
they are actually powered by the latest
CPU architecture available on the market
so these are powered by the new Intel
scalable processors the second
generation codenamed cascade Lake and
they offer the highest frequency
available on DCP with up to three point
eight gigahertz in all quarter ball
let's talk a little bit more about
compute optimized VMs
as you can see they already come with
multiple shapes and oceans so today they
arranged from 4 to 6 TV CPUs from 16 to
240 gigabytes of memory offering you a 4
to 1 gigabyte per vcp ratio they also
enable you to manage or use multiple
storage options so you can use network
attached storage persistent disk or you
can use local SSD local storage as with
any other GC instance we're also happy
that we are introducing these VMs with
the new networking caps that we have
available that were announced today so
they offer directly up to 32 gigabits
per second and going beyond the shapes
and the hardware we've really focused on
making the computer optimized VMs the
best option for you when you have new
real-time and highly demanding workloads
so these VMs you get full transparency
into the underlying hardware you get
explicit Numa visibility so that you get
the best performance across the
different VM pipes and different VM
sizes you also get very tight
consistency and very predictable
performance so that you can bet your
most intensive applications on those VMs
for those of you that are looking to do
more fine-tuning of your performance you
also get access to things such as the
processor power state so that you can
find you in your application performance
on those feeders
so to summarize what we covered for
compute optimize VMs these are one of
our new introductions to DCP as we look
to cover more of the edge cases that you
might have for your different workloads
they have the highest performance per
core available on Google compute engine
they are powered by the latest intel's
second-generation scalable processors
and go up to three point eight gigahertz
in all quarter both in addition they
have minimal variability very high
consistency and offer you multiple
shapes so that you can find the one
thing which is looking for and fits your
workload this makes them a great fit for
multiple applications including
multiplayer gaming high-performance
computing video encoding real-time web
serving and others
now let's move to some of the other
highly demanding workloads different
types of highly demanding workloads one
great example here might be databases
specifically hi and databases we see a
lot of customers running large ERP
systems for example a zippy ERP systems
and what they are looking for it
typically is the fact that as their
database continues to grow they are
looking for an infrastructure that will
grow with them and will be able to scale
with their needs while they think about
this they are also looking for an
infrastructure that continues to give
them the benefits of running on the
cloud the flexibility that comes with
that and the ability to have higher
fault tolerance and many of the great
features that we talked about this is
where the memory optimized VMs come into
the picture and the way we really define
memory optimized VMs on Google compute
engine is that they are the large memory
VMs one terabyte and higher these that
typically tend to be multiple socket
systems very large systems and tend to
have a very high amount of memory per
core so that they can continue to scale
with your memory needs memory optimized
VMs are built for memory intensive
workloads including in-memory databases
and in-memory analytics they provide the
highest gigabyte per core available on
GCP with options that range from 15 to
24 or 25 gigabytes per V CPU and they
also offer you the lowest dollar per
gigabyte available with these
configurations multiple shapes are
available for you under the memory
optimized VM category ranging from one
point five terabytes up to the sixth and
twelve terabyte VMs that we just
announced today and with plans to even
extend up to 18 terabytes and more
if you're thinking about how the
infrastructure continues to scale with
your database and scale with your needs
then one of the things we've really had
as one of our guiding principles for
those PMS is the speed at which we've
been trying to add new sizes and
continue to scale with your requirements
so you can see here that in
approximately the last 18 months those
VMs have increased in sizing by more
than 10x for the number of course they
provide and 60x
for the amount of memory available on
those VMs my favorite part about memory
optimized VMs though is that they
continue to give you all the benefits of
Google compute engine that we've just
described so they are fully flexible and
they provide you with very high
availability let's talk about
availability with memory optimized VMs
you continue to get live migration
supporting zero downtime for your most
critical applications and for those of
you not familiar with live migration
it's simply our way of making sure that
maintenance events are transparent to
your workloads when Google Cloud expects
that or sees them that the maintenance
event is about to happen
we transparently spin up another version
of your VM copy all the data over so
that you don't have to experience any
downtime or impact on your application
and this continues to be one of the
things that we keep as a core part of
infrastructure as we expand to more
sizes another thing here is flexibility
if you're running the type of deployment
and the type of workload where you
expect your requirements to change
months over months then you definitely
don't want to be stuck into a reserved
size we're moving to a different size
requires a different contract or a
different commitment and this is why the
commitments that we provide for memory
optimized VMs are really just for memory
optimized VMs you can use the same
commitment for one for a one terabyte VM
you can add to that and use it for four
terabyte VMs or you can divide it across
different VMs as you
scale out or scale up it's really up to
you it's one big category that you can
divide it the way you see fit as you
scale up or as you scale down another
great thing about memory optimized VMs
is the simplicity these are native gcpd
arms native Google compute engine VMs
they fully support all the Google
compute engine features and capabilities
you use them directly from the console
from g-cloud from the API you can use
labels you can use any other features
that you're using today including the
policies for example that you have
defined for your organization's and
manage them exactly as any other small
VM available as part of your deployment
the last part and mention about the
memory optimized VMs is our focus on
making sure that we introduce new
innovation as we continue to expand our
sizing a great example of that is the
support for the latest memory
technologies and you might have recently
seen some announcements from Google
compute engine where where we talked
about Intel update DC persistent memory
this technology is specifically useful
for those of you who have been seeing a
gap between the cost and the performance
available from DRAM and that available
from flash or from SSD if you have
applications that require better
performance than storage but cannot you
cannot afford to have them running on
DRAM due to the cost associated with
that
then this fits in into that gap over
there as you can see it fits in that
place between memory and storage the
other great thing about this technology
is that it also gives you the
availability or the ability to have
persistent memory so that for certain
applications the application going down
doesn't mean that you actually lose all
of your data even though you had get the
performance or a performance that's very
close to that that you get with DRAM
Google cloud has done a lot of early
work with this technology and focused on
availing it first so that you can test
it on our platform with that we give you
much higher density per VM than that
which can only be available with the
regular memory technologies
approximately 4x more memory at a
significantly lower cost it tends to be
much faster and lower latency the
storage and is a great fit for in-memory
databases across the board today we do
have in our alpha testing programs a few
shapes available where you can test
Intel DC persistent memory for yourself
and add with a small note with the 96 V
CPU note up to 6.7 terabyte across the
RAM and obtain DC persistent memory if
you have workloads where you don't need
the performance of duran and you want to
leverage the TCO improvements this might
be a great fit for your testing
so let's summarize the different
instance types we've covered we thought
how we talked about how with Google
compute engine
you get very flexible general-purpose
VMs the general-purpose VMs tend to be
the most flexible and the most simple to
use they are great for a wide range of
workloads across web serving databases
gaming and others they also give you the
ability to right-size the VM to exactly
what you're looking for you get
recommendations that help you with
making sure that you're picking the
right size they are very flexible and
enable you to directly attach or did the
app or detach accelerators or storage
options then we covered the compute
optimized VMs one of the new things that
we're introducing on Google compute
engine for your very performance
intensive workloads compute optimized
VMs offered the highest performance
procore available on GCP they are a
great fit for triple-a gaming HPC
high-performance websites and some types
of scientific modeling they are
available in multiple shapes and enable
you to get approximately 3.8 gigahertz
in all quarter Bo we talked about memory
optimized VMs and these VMs are a great
fit for your memory intensive workloads
they have a lot of sizes that go from 1
terabyte to approximately 12 terabytes
today with more coming they are a great
fit for high end databases in memory
databases as well as real-time and
in-memory analytics they also offer you
great flexibility since you can always
scale up or scale down or divide your
commitments across them in different
shapes and sizes
we also talked about preemptable yams
which is really a simple flag that you
can add to any of the Empire across the
different types we talked about
regardless of your CPU and memory and
performance requirements and once you
add that flag you automatically get the
most economic option for bursty
fault-tolerant workloads this is a great
fit if you're running a rendering job
a bad job or some simulations that you
just need to compute for but you don't
care if it gets preempted and then
continues to run again and you have that
kind of intelligence into your platform
so to summarize today we really focus on
how we can make some of your
decision-making simpler on Google
compute engine by making sure that we
always continue to focus on simplicity
flexibility and efficiency we talked
about how you can use simple guidelines
to make simple choices on whether you
just want a wide range of flexible
options with general-purpose VMs or
you're looking for the most performant
option available with compute optimized
VMs we also covered have how for some of
your very memory intensive applications
with memory optimized shapes you get the
benefits of the cloud with the sizing
that you're looking for and you get a
lot of benefits related to availability
and flexibility even as you go to these
large sizes we hope that give that that
gives you a general overview into the
options available for you and makes it a
little bit easier to decide on what
you're looking for on Google compute
engine
[Music]